foreign
[Music]
I'm down for the count oh yeah next game
you just taped the special yeah yeah I'm
just trying to get it off me oh
look at this that's a Sally original
that's a great shot great shot you got
the lady the hot lady in the front
smiling I love that checking out the
package got your got your ass right
there yep
how many shows did you do we did four
shows first three were were good like I
think we got something but the last show
was magic that's what I heard you need
the magic I was texting people for
updates I was getting Sal accused of
sending me updates James Webb who's
directing and sending me updates uh
little garissimo sending me up there oh
yeah everyone's sending me updates yeah
I told them that the first two shows you
were playing like prevent defense is
like don't [__] up yes don't [__] up I
was stiff yeah but I was nervous thank
God I did four you got to do a multiple
um and Wilson's hosting you forget this
guy's a pro he's been doing comedy since
81. I forget that all the time there he
is as well uh and so he's really getting
that energy going so that was huge and
then Gary comes and he's such a fun hang
well oh great hang he was bombing in The
Green Room there's Gary look at that
doesn't even move he plants those two
tiny feet and just stays there this is
why he thinks we can get away with
eating like pigs on the road because
we don't move on stage right we're both
immobile yeah yes and by the way he was
in charge of ordering food all weekend
and he blew it what he said I said we
got to get lunch on Saturday he said I
got it the queefiest what was that it
said Rose all day on the wall there was
a trans guy singing a Melody you were
there salicus walked in two girls though
my Dad's here I'm sorry I mean it was
brutal we were the oldest food
stunk we didn't even eat we left because
it was too queefy and uh we had to bail
oh my God so we all gave veter [__] then
we went to a diner him missing it is oh
that's a great shot too holy [__] look
at that look at the Asian guy with the
give it a goog shirt up front wow yeah
look at that I don't know that's the
beginning of the end uh this is the end
there you go that's epic that's a great
shot man Sally killed it yeah so we got
it should we bring our guests in here I
think he's taking a wee-wee okay
all right all right well uh yeah man uh
that's great I'm I'm proud of you thank
you the other special in the can yeah
gotta feel the good feels good I mean
now it's just a matter of building new
material bombing all day well you did
you this Norman pulls a [__] move
with me last night I got Courtside
Knicks tickets I was like Mark come to
the game with me and Mark says Ah I got
four sets and I said you just taped a
special so I'm not gonna push you
because I understand I'm that guy too
well I can't take a night off
but
you blew it that blew it uh I was on the
Jumbotron I know we could have been on
that would have been a great Point
together I know that that well jumbo
killed me I was like damn it I'm bombing
at the seller what you're on the jumbo
you should have come with me I was
wrecked I was wasted at that game oh
look at me look at that look how cute
little colored shirt on
adorable in my next throwback jacket too
dude I was oh yeah I was bombed in that
game with my friend Chase we were
wrecked and it's open bar right oh yeah
yeah open bar there's like a little VIP
room and they take care of you yeah I
was in the elevator with Edie Falco and
I was like don't say anything don't say
anything I just told him I was like my
favorite show of all time thank you so
much
Jackie I saw Troy Bond posted a bunch of
pictures with her and it just said Mom
she rules she's so cool and then uh
Randall went for 57 career high it was
epic but we lost it was a tough one they
just all their they were missing all
their stars and the the T wolves and
they still somehow pulled it out on us
it was brewed they couldn't miss they
were missing this star too I'll tell you
that I was pretty I was pretty bummed
there'll be other times but there'll be
other ones that was the day of I had I
was no I should get it but that's why I
didn't push you because I was like
you're [__] up yeah I [__] up
because you need to you need to do the
fun stuff too every once in a while
you're right you're right and I'm also
biased because I'm Nick obsessed sure
but yeah well also I I was so hungover
on Sunday on the flight back then I had
some guilt with that now dude I'm dying
today I thought I was gonna puke all
morning yeah I mean I was like I was
doing the belching you know the the
preventative belt yes and I was doing
like you know the running trying to
sweat it off
I've been there chin coming out of me
yes and I was on the flight from Chicago
and I was getting the salivation you
know when you're about to yak and I kept
having to like my stomach is gurgling
salvating sweating and kept having to
move and look out the window and the
lady next to me was like this guy's on
drugs or something it was bad remember
what happened you remember that happened
and there's no Wi-Fi and you're like I
need a distraction something I was so
hungover the other day I was trying to
watch Jurassic Park on a flight and I
was too hungover to pay attention to
Jurassic Park yes do you know how
[__] hung over we have to be to not
pay attention to a blockbuster how many
dinosaur head down what do you do how do
you cope with that on a plane it's you
watch something I'll watch I need to
watch like a Marvel movie something dumb
as [__] yeah you're like a Dilophosaurus
you got a yeah
anything that's gonna take my mind off
the pain I'm in yeah and then a lot of
coffee and a lot of water
yeah there was one point on the ride
there I was hung over I couldn't roll
down the window I couldn't do it hey
let's get in here man get in here no no
no hey what's shaking man how's it going
thanks for joining us yeah of course I
like you guys going raw no intro no no
interest
good to have you everywhere yeah yeah
I've been following you guys a little
bit
everywhere I passed through I see you
guys on Marquees or whatever Marquis
yeah yeah oh on the road yeah on the
road yeah so in a weird way that sounded
Grand but he's talking about like the
Toledo funny bone no not at all man what
was that place you did in New Orleans oh
the uh Joy The Joy how was that that was
nice okay how hard are you on the road
right now uh shoot how many days have we
done now like
about six weeks yeah yeah you know
you're working hard when your tour
manager is wiped yeah that's just a
comic yeah dude yeah no it's been a
minute
um how many days at a time are you out
uh like five or basically so we did a
Sprinter for like three weeks oh nice oh
nice yeah and then had a three week
break and then we're doing the bus for
the next five and then yeah doing the
bus I heard man I love it yeah do you
sleep on it
um yeah I mean I think you get used to
it after a while but that first week
when you get the bunk off that's you
gotten it yet yeah you know what we get
a lot is I mean first off you eliminate
travel you just wake up in a new city
which is cool but I do feel like every
day you're like are we all sick or is
this just allergies yeah and then you're
like I think it's allergies I think but
then you hate to be that I'm The
Stereotype Jew I'm just like NASA Court
where's the [__] NASA Court I don't
even know these terms you sniff it up oh
you know it's really doing the bus is
Jay Moore
all right he's [__] Genie butt oh my
God it was a leap that took me a second
but he's doing the bus
uh yeah yeah the bunk cough I've never
heard of that yeah it's like from it's
like from the little uh air conditioner
well you gotta turn that off dude you
can't be air in your face all night yeah
that's the mistake I made the first time
done the bunk jerk yeah we try to not
move like Anne Frank on the burst in
France well you don't want to make any
noise and have anybody hear you yeah
lying beneath the floorboard let's see a
tell joke uh bunk bed is a good training
for jail what are you doing up there
nothing watch your eyelids
watch your eyelids
yeah yeah you know you've done the jerk
not on the bus wow dude bunk jerk how
many have you had yeah oh I don't know
you're jerking off in the little thing
well I mean the shades open no the
shades closed uh and it's four in the
morning you know you wake up you're like
I got a phone I gotta suck
you know that's like uh The Hazing of
the of the animals just like some dude
just jerking off remember the what was
that
huh that's where Limp Biscuit comes from
really oh that's how Fred Durst was born
yeah he comes from a cookie
but oh damn yeah that that's the [__] we
were on a bus and our bus driver this
guy Jeff is awesome he's like a
character I just saw a jar of pickles by
where he's driving I was kind of like I
love to just eat pickles he's like well
I don't want to get too dependent on
coffee late night and the acidity keeps
me awake oh that's crazy that's
interesting actually that tastes yeah it
does wake you up a little bit that's a
pro it's a pro but he was telling me I
was like who's been a lot and he's
telling me dude he drives bands or do
you ever ask your guy like who's been a
pain honestly we no because we've had
we've had some pretty like we've had
character bus drivers but in a way where
we just kind of leave him alone oh
really yeah yeah yeah I'll let you
finish I'll tell you about this one this
dude this dude is great and he was
telling me I was like give me a comic
who is a lot and he goes he goes Tom
Segura would you're not supposed to poop
on the bus oh yeah you're not supposed
to poop but he would do I guess they're
called hot bags yeah and he would just
say like hey we left three hot bags
so you just take like a bag and poop in
it and then you're like all right that's
it say Bust jerk better than bust poop
way better all right which one do you
feel more regretful after though ah true
either way jerk yeah what's your story
oh well I don't want to out him I mean
it's a pretty common name his name's
Bill uh uh yeah yeah yeah yeah
everybody knows that pooping on the bus
is okay
so stupid
okay
this deal he had like really big stature
his eyes were kind of crazy bill yeah
big Bill yeah bus driver not a comic yes
oh sorry sorry oh I was like Bill Burr
yeah man now he would um and his diet
was he was just going to Walmart
and he'd get slabs of like beef and he'd
cook them on a George Foreman whoa yeah
and he just he was just kind of like
this like I wouldn't be surprised if
there's like slabs of human like they
just kind of had this vibe to him where
he's like I'm going to get beef we're
like all right bill yeah damn yeah bus
drivers are too comfortable they're up
there in their own world no one's
talking to them no one's shaming them so
they get weird the pickles the beef I
love it I had a guy on Schumer's butt he
would just eat Altoids and I was like
dude how many Altoids have you had he
would have packs of tins and he's
ridiculous [__] well that and you can't
fall asleep on an out toy because you're
you're so minted up yeah so that was his
trick damn yeah he smelled better than
the beef and pickles yeah everyone they
just used to do meth yeah yeah those
were the days I think there's still some
methy oh it was out there yeah man yeah
we had another driver he just like sure
like kind of look at porn while he drove
hey really yeah it was like it was like
soft cord just like girls in bikinis but
kind of oh that's nothing that's fine
that's all right I do that too
like man you've been jacking off he's
like look I gotta stay away yeah I
respect that the problem is when you
finish though then you start dozing
that's true after your jerk don't ask me
how I know
I can't we we don't do that we do the
some low brow [__] like James uh who you
know you guys know obviously directed
your special James Webbie just like
shredded he's like the dude that we we
show up at the hotel at like midnight
and he's like I'm going to the gym and
we're like now nah he just jumps on the
bench 350. above wow so he's a dude on
the bus in between the bunks he's just
doing tricep dips and we're like all
right moving bus just doing tricep dips
but late at night open veeder's little
curtain up and James would just farting
there
little just a little bus camaraderie
yeah
yeah and Peter's used to living in a
Nook I assume he lives in a tree
he's in a tree house yeah he's making
cookies with his wife
but yeah the buzz just I'm so sick of
flying so the bus sounds pretty mad the
bus is good just the stress of travel
yeah it's just it's a lot and then also
like we're with a crew so when we fly
you know I've you know James he's got so
much camera gear there's always there's
always an issue at airport security yeah
tonight I get to watch his anger
problems kind of unfold yeah well he's
like it's a [__] camera dude I'm like
[__] this guy's on Roy's I think I don't
know what happened it might choke you
out you better chill out so you're doing
theaters I am yeah on this run that's
fun yeah it's it's pretty cool I think
you got a biggie what is it uh Radio
City no Town Hall Town Hall sorry yeah
the other one yeah have you ever done
Town Hall not Town Hall no it's
beautiful is it it's one of the best
venues I think in in the country hell
yeah it's so classic yeah they do the
Patrice O'Neill benefit there every year
damn uh and it's like coming up on the
fourth is it April 4th dang um it's it's
don't you think it's one of the best
rooms beautiful old historic pretty it's
like tight in there it's small it's
right in Midtown you're gonna love it it
feels like it's 300 people but it's
right what is it like 1500 or 2 000 yeah
yeah look at that it's like epic man
yeah no I'm I'm stoked I haven't
performed here in like three years maybe
so nice come back and to have the room
be so big it's pretty crazy hell yeah so
you you made it big uh what on the
internet yeah sketches and whatnot yeah
uh it's it's funny because I was gonna
stand up before and I I like really
resisted the internet but I kind of like
gave in at some point and thought
there's no way especially in La like you
just you can't get time right so I
thought like all right if I can make
stupid little sketches maybe this will
you know I could like con some promoter
into like giving me 10 minutes yeah
seven or some [__] well it's status you
know look at these fall look at all
these views yeah okay this guy's
something yeah so
um then like the internet stuff kind of
like really ramped up out of nowhere
um just by way of working with my
podcast co-host Cody yeah and the Pod is
huge right yeah we've uh we've been
fortunate to do pretty Mr Beast on yeah
yeah we did how was that it's pretty
great I I'm I made him put on a Gucci
suit and then like I was kind of joking
I'm like you hate poor people right and
uh he's got a lot of young fans and they
thought it was like serious oh so they
got really mad at him and young people
yeah the worst yeah they're making
little tick tocks like the truth about
Mr beast wow I hate poor people yeah
it's pretty good and then he cured
blindness and they all turn I don't get
the beef he's helping me we made a
thousand people see yeah but that's but
people honestly the people getting mad
about it is probably helping him because
it's just more I guess eyeballs yeah hey
I guess but it's still weird like the
like I don't know we'll get into that
later he seems like a great guy all
hockey yeah yeah he is is he six six or
something I would say like six four or
something like six three he's big big
guy yeah how'd he get so big
um that size or no on YouTube I think he
ate well
but he just but like how did how did he
blow up because I don't know I see his
name everywhere but I don't really know
much about it he started on YouTube by
doing these really kind of absurd videos
where he would just film himself and
he'd say I'm gonna count to a million
you know and then the next one would be
like I'm gonna count to two million and
then you know or I'll I'll watch this
video for 24 hours straight and the
video will be 24 hours long and you'd
actually do it what's pretty crazy is
all those videos he said no one ever
watched past one minute interesting so
he could have literally did anything
after the first five wow look at these
views on the two-day video 50 million
yeah wow last month 125 million 100
won't take that Oscars
honestly absolutely the Oscars is like
13 million views or something yeah they
should just get Rogan to host the Oscars
yeah yeah really totally put this Oscar
up my ass gotta wait till the end I put
50 Oscars in my ass I'm gonna count how
many people actually saw one of these
best picture nominees no one let's do a
quick video
what are we drinking here this looks
beautifully garnished yeah we got a
watermelon gen Fizz yes I heard you like
watermelon and gin yeah I was trying to
bring you guys a bottle of you heard of
empress 1908 it's like a it's a purple
gin so it's kind of like this you know
it's kind of corny but it's got a cool
like effect when you pour it in with the
watermelon juice it like like it changes
color oh yeah yeah all right I'm using
um misguided today that's fine these
guys are from Brooklyn they're a friend
of the bar Joey roses they uh they're
Lower East Side base like most their
bars are down there they distribute to
so that's a summer drink right there I
look I'm getting into the different
color I've been using a vermouth it's
lighter and I drink a lot negroni's in
Manhattans at home yeah and it just
looks a little off the color but it
tastes so [__] good if you're really
good uh vermouth you know yeah yeah this
is great this is very good I mean that
is a top-notch Jesus yeah it's fresh as
hell it tastes like water slides like
summertime yeah it goes down easy
uh you got a busy day tonight or a busy
night no no I'm just chilling and then
we got Portland Maine tomorrow oh great
yeah get a lobster roll yeah dude that's
a fun town yeah that's a really nice
Town yeah I've been there once
um I'm allergic as hell to fish so I
can't what I know it sucks damn all fish
yeah you can't have any fish pretty much
shrimp no no whoa
[__] yeah all right exactly yeah
holy hell yeah that's what my mom used
to say so have you been like have you
done like a challenge I think they call
it a test whatever yeah I've done one of
those and and you what are they just
jamming up depending you after you they
take like they take like a panel of like
15 needles and they just like prick it
on your back wait this is a Mr Beast
video yeah yeah I know yeah I put 30
needles yeah which one of them got me
high not and uh yeah it came back like
all Seafood will just [__] me wow yeah
damn that's crazy what was crazier is
when I was younger because my mom ate a
lot of fish like just naturally because
of her culture so she didn't believe me
so she used to feed me fish
I'm just sitting there she's probably
building building immunity honestly yeah
yeah but I sit there and like my throat
is like getting kind of tight and I'm
like I can't eat it and she's like keep
going wow actually he out Jude you that
is crazy yeah I eat crustaceans
and send locks and salmon well yeah oh
my God a Jew that can't eat salmon would
be torture white fish gefilte fish
Big Fish culture we're a big fish big
fish culture wait what's Mom what's
Mom's culture it's a fun bit I've never
said like publicly oh really oh you
won't say yeah wow so you're playing
every angle here yeah yeah it could be
anything could be anything that's good
because you're kind of ambiguous
racially she could be half black half
Samoan half asian half Latino that's too
many houses oh yeah
it could be all of them you know I could
be a quarter everything you don't know
I'm going but it's Asian because you
didn't call him out on his math huh
that was [__] racist dude that was
Despicable you take that hate elsewhere
okay yeah dude
um I'm going I think it's something
Latino based well not exactly gonna tell
us anyway no I don't know he's not gonna
tell us but well he got watermelon all
right
that was more subtle
it was a dumb question and feel free to
kick me in the balls here this is where
I get weird I'd love to okay
it's weird that you could be gender flu
but you can't be racially fluid because
you Rachel Dole is all well but you
literally can be three four different
races so can't isn't that more make more
sense to be racially fluid
I wonder if we'll get to a point with
23andMe where they can tell you what
gender you are like if you were born the
wrong gender I doubt it I think maybe
they can tell taste buds dude can they
yeah I've never done instruct if it's
here you know if it's in your head it's
not in your on your body yeah yeah the
chromosomes and the biology is still the
same hmm so yeah it's all it's up here
yeah yeah so I don't know I like
racially fluid dude all right I got
something there yeah but you are
racially fluid I think so I think I
qualify a little bit
because everyone in New York wants to be
racist and it's like they're just trying
to compute yeah what are you yes where
are you from originally uh I was
actually born in Toronto but then that
doesn't help this is not helpful most
nationalities of any City yeah yeah and
Canadians the whole wrench in the in the
races Toronto though that is east coast
true but very diverse City
I'm thinking it's a mix
yeah but with what I'll have no idea
we don't care anyway I don't see you
race
or whatever
but yeah good for you yeah man I think
gender fluid would bail a lot of you
know streamers out when they get caught
saying the n word
sorry I identified differently that day
Oh you mean racial fluid yeah yeah yeah
for sure I don't know dude Rachel told
us all got just destroyed oh yeah we've
talked about her a lot on this pod yeah
she really reached did you buy her only
fans no I didn't
you didn't know you didn't know that no
yeah we did I mean I think we just found
that out like a week ago but she's
what does she do on it feet
only women no I think she's more than
feet I thought it was one of the feet
women women can make a lot of money on
feet dudes love feet yeah man I don't
get it I think specific dudes left feet
so it's like a very small minority of
guys love it and they'll pay anything
for it which minority yeah dude yeah
which one fluid
shouldn't it just be free is the apology
for like it's my only fans that's up for
free like oh yeah sorry it's free for
the black community
at all to the NAACP that would help hmm
well I don't know what she'd do for work
now and maybe it's just only fans maybe
it's only fans it's funny it's like only
fans and Cameo it's like a weird
crossover yeah it's like only fans is
really Cameo for people I mean you see
you can see some celebs on there I guess
yeah I wonder Cameo we need to get some
cameos some weird ones you can get some
interesting people that's crazy ones
Alec Baldwin let's give it a shot doing
it no no you say give it a shot thank
you one of Rachel Dole is all the only
fan takes uh the black Amex all right
there's your feet one you're giving it
away for free doley well I'm sure
someone you can't you screenshot it oh
yeah good point it's about support you
know
damn there she is she fooled a lot of
people she fooled black people for a
while did she yeah she was in the NAACP
now Seattle which no she headed ACP so
there you go
I think in like I don't know 50 years
race you will be allowed to transition
racially and then we're gonna go she was
like Rosa Parks everybody
yeah I don't know about that
mark my words
if you want to say this about gender 50
years ago people like oh shut up she was
like the first to do it that girl bad
baby that rapper she did it too bad baby
the the catch me outside girl oh her
yeah she just posted some pictures where
she looked like she was black fishing up
she's kind of hot I don't know a million
dollars on only fans the first day yeah
what first of all when she turned 18
yeah that's pretty [__] creepy yeah
it's weird to have a countdown yeah it's
weird if there were people waiting yeah
right yeah well I mean the fact that
there's like a grand opening for your
consent age yeah it's kind of [__]
dark I bet Leo's got a couple of those
running you know people like those
clocks that say like Mexico New York
he's probably got one with like eight
different women he's got a talent scout
the way the NBA has he's like see what
you can find coming out of high school
yes yes get her an SUV
all right wow is that
her interesting
how old is she a kind of a teenager no
she's 20 something
yeah so have you ever had a guy go hey
you [__] slur and you're like that's
the wrong one yeah really yeah do you
correct them no no no no
yeah but don't you think would make them
more mad if you were like actually try
again yeah like it's a game yeah just
running through yeah Jeopardy I like it
the Daily Double yeah I get those DMS
all the time I just laugh I'm like yeah
close what's your favorite food to eat
oh water
a big water guy yeah big water guy he's
a genius I'm gonna do this with gay yeah
you're like are you gay I'm like maybe
I'm all over the place this is genius I
love this because it's all so stupid put
too much emphasis on race and all this
[__] anyway so this is great just do you
yeah be Noel that's it that's my race
blow me
[__] blow me dude that's a weird race
blow me just erase the people like just
suck my dick dude yeah yeah I think I
know what it is just dude really make a
guess if I get it will you say same
right I don't know it can't say it okay
so half uh Puerto Rican that was when my
mind went to the visco Filipino oh
that's pretty good yeah
philorica because uh your first name is
Hispanic name yeah but that's also could
be Filipino um I thought it was a French
name Filipino is where you get some
ambiguity too and he said his mom loved
to cook fish it's part of her culture
that's part of their culture
no that's fine all right a Puerto Rican
a Puerto Rican we could be it's like it
could be right you know Sia the singer
yeah she won't show her face this is
your Sia thing that's on my race dude I
love it I'm just waiting for this no no
one knows what she looks like they know
but like in other media she doesn't
intentionally show it oh I'm an idiot I
thought it was all a big secret how
about like the gorillas that band oh
yeah another one they were they were
[__] don't they have new [__] out too
they were good they were good I listen
to their new album is it pretty good
yeah it was fun what kind of music do
you listen to like rock uh
I try to like listen to a lot but
primarily a lot of rap do you like the
Buena Vista Social Club what
what is that
Cuban we ruled out Cuban
nice dude
I was like is that a car club like what
is that dude
yeah nah
um what was I gonna say about oh yeah
you're gonna say something oh yeah no
I'm just waiting for like 23andMe to try
to cut me a huge sponsor to admit oh yes
that would be smart yeah I I think it's
pretty cool would you ever do it maybe
it's I think it's kind of cool to just
know even though I mean although they're
gonna they're using it for evil already
yeah there's gonna be a clone it's such
horseshit because we all go race doesn't
matter we're all equal then we're like I
wonder what I am why do we need to know
so bad if it doesn't matter if we're all
the same or whatever the hell because
we're not all the same because they tell
you more than just your background it's
kind of interesting
well race and culture is interesting it
isn't we have differences and you know
it's fun I think we just get annoyed
when it's someone's entire personality
yeah because those are the people when
they then they find out that they
weren't even that and you're like will
you base your whole identity on the LIE
yeah those are the people I think bug us
a little bit and see ya Mencia Ned
wholeness right that's his name yeah
he's not even Mexican Well now we're
doing that with uh disorders like I'm
autistic I'm uh depressed or whatever or
I have this and that and you're like no
she'd never pick one that makes you look
bad yeah you know it's never like I'm a
narcissist I have irritable bowel
syndrome why are you posting about that
I'm a sociopath you know it's always
like the victim ones you're right it's
never like I'm sorry I have narcissistic
personality exactly exactly never never
like I was uh I'm abused or I'm
depressed it's always something where
you're like oh I'm sorry yeah it's never
like I'm a serial killer I was a bully
yeah
did you make a victim I'm I have a
problem I'm a serial killers like well
sounds like they're the victims yeah I'm
a victim too yeah you think I want to
kill people it's awful I was born this
way I'm just laughing at IBS being your
thing
I'm posting your diarrhea like uh it
came too quick we're doing a March very
close to a bathroom
there's a girl that works at the bar who
said every guy she's ever dated has had
IBS and I told her I think they're just
trying to hide for you in the bathroom
yeah that is the thing I like you know
look there was that point in the
relationship where you're like you know
because you want to eat fun Foods
together but what you can do pizza early
on you do like I mean Indian early on is
a [__] just love dude that's love
it's a role it doesn't like you too yeah
totally that's what I like about my lady
she's got crazy lactose and then I I
show up with a piece of pizza she's like
bring it on and I'm like what about the
the bathroom she's like I'll deal with
that then you're dealing with it
I'm okay with it but she's the one just
destroying the bowl damn but she's like
I'll let's do it it's like a guy who
drinks you're like I'm gonna be hungover
I got a big day tomorrow but bring on
the booze I'm sure she really
appreciates you sharing all this oh
she's a big [__]
that's uh that is cool though I I've
dated someone like that too who had uh
stomach issues I won't say who in my
story but uh she had big stomach issues
and same [__] she would eat the pizza
and I was like that's what you want she
can rally but I've had the people too
where you ever date a vegan and the and
they're like this is pretty good pizza
and you're like just have one real
[__] slice I know and then tell me
that's real pizza I'll eat the vegan
with you like you know to be a you know
to be supportive every once in a while
but like let's be real would you ever
convince any of you bro yeah she's not
supporting you ah that's a good point
it's probably the vegans you got to
cater to them they never they rarely
come the other way but yeah sorry no I
was gonna say would you ever get him to
Cave just like eat a little cheese with
it yeah yeah they would and they would
cave usually because cheese real cheese
dude yeah well that's amazing the
hardest thing for me about being vegan
would not eat would be that would
honestly be like the cheese and the eggs
I eat eggs and cheese like every day I
love eggs I mean meat it's not like I
could give it up easily but like that
would be easier for me to give up than
yeah than the other stuff isn't oral not
vegan
I'm just saying it's all animal
product but you're not eating it I guess
you slang you say you eat it you swallow
saliva jizz but if you shoot but if you
Anthony Hopkins in Silence of the Lambs
that's not vegan right right okay but if
you're just licking okay so she could
buy that logic she could lick some more
pizza yeah
that's a good point
what about multiple migs the guy in the
cell next
he's the only guy in history who knows a
guy's name
that movie still rocks it was on cable
recently and holy [__] the last few
scenes are you a big movie guy uh in a
way but I'm just still picturing the
jizz coming out of your hand right there
dude we I was walking over here they
have a Dungeons and Dragons movie coming
out I'm like are you
what yeah when's Solitaire the movie
coming out give us a [__]
Dungeons and Dragons they're really
they're really running out of [__] you
didn't play you didn't play grown up no
I didn't you did no no no no no damn it
it's definitely not black
bearing it down all right my brother
played he was a big goth queef you know
yeah black makeup oh yeah I could kind
of see your brother being into that I
know a lot of people that play now
though we're now yes oh no it's kind of
like a it's like a Resurgence that's
true yeah but watch out for those guys
yeah I know a dude who he'll like play
over Zoom like he'll be on a long drive
just taking a call
yeah and like is it you no no hell no
she had a long drive and uh that's how
your bus driver stays awake yeah yeah
it's I just don't get it because like my
uh my brother would play with like 80
nerds you know they'd be in a warehouse
just playing this [__] at eight in the
morning and all that and I was like this
is I had to go because I was I was the
younger brother so my mom didn't want to
watch she's like go with him so I'd just
be sitting there like this and I'm like
we have video games yeah they would
literally draw a card and be like hit
point you'd lose a hit point and they're
like oh okay one hit point down and
you're like we got we got uh Tetris we
got Call of Duty we got Zelda we got
Mario what are we doing with this [__]
dude they have a Mario movie coming out
now too yeah it actually looks kind of
cool the trailer one are you kidding me
except Rogan is Donkey Kong is in uh
Chris Brown is Mario yeah I don't see
Chris Pratt as Mario though yeah yeah
but I bet it's getting an Italian actor
I saw the trailer and this it's like a
slow version of the score where I was
like this is like [__] incredible did
you feel like they should have gotten
Sebastian to do Mario's oh yes Sebastian
is Mario what's with all these coins
everywhere I mean I could see it sucking
too but it looks kind of cool it looks
great that's pretty yeah I remember when
that game came out on N64 that was like
the craziest [__] oh yeah
start a Mario Kart
it's maybe like the best community game
yes yeah easily that and golden eye
golden eye was good too but Mario
there's something about Mario Kart that
was like it still had the violence yeah
we were racing I mean it was pretty
great yeah I feel like that's the one
that anyone's willing to pick up yes I
feel like any other game you kind of
have to convince people but Mario Kart
people they're like yeah what player did
you go with toad toad yeah I was a Yoshi
guy interested I was the girl Peach yes
Bowser Bowser he's heavy and fast yeah
N64 really [__] [__] up I mean like
that wrestling game no mercy was like oh
bro we used to all play that [__] Dan
soda and I used to play that constantly
it's me soda Anthony DeVito Greg Stone
We Had Creative character we created our
own characters oh yeah yeah it was great
which if you want to wreck anything
based off a video game The Last of Us
that's my wreck
let's play the game it's the closest two
and it's they didn't like I heard them
the show is pretty good
dude you know what I got a good wreck
for you and it's from our boy H Foley
who was on the ru garbage app who
wrecked it on the app and I watched it
because of Foley the movie dinner rush
it's on Amazon dinner Danny Aiello it's
[__] good really it starts like kind
of weird we were like where's this going
that's a good movie man good Little
Indie movie like 20 years ago
I wrecked at the Colin coin the other
night so I'm I'm awaiting attacks [__]
you or or I liked it he's very
passionate with his responses well off
your wreck I watch Megan what do you
think I thought it was fun bro Megan was
awesome Lonnie Chang [__] kills
Ronnie Chang was awesome I liked it I
mean it's campy but it's supposed to be
yeah it's a [__] doll killing people
yes I liked it it's basically Chucky
it's girl Chucky yes girl Chucky exactly
but it was kind of more fun than Chucky
definitely yeah a little smarter yeah no
I like Megan a lot what's what's another
movie you've seen recently
hey folks we might be drunk Brody by
manscaped you know we gotta trim those
pubes you've heard all about it's hot
girl summer but what about hot men
get ready for hot guys summer and level
up with manscape manscape is dedicated
to upping your confidence by giving you
all the tools you need to be well
groomed I got a couple raises at home I
throw one in the suitcase one in the
bathroom one at my uh bedside in case
I'm about to get spiffy next to the lady
the performance package 2.0 is a
lifesaver it includes the essential
lawnmower 4.0 which is a waterproof
cordless body hair trimmer the weed
whacker 2.0 perfect for grooming those
ear and nose hairs and some extra
goodies for those crown jewels refresh
your balls with crop reviver ball toner
and the crop preserver ball deodorant
while you're at it deal with those
toenails too with the shears 2.0 nail
kit to round out your grooming
collectione get 20 off and free shipping
with the code drunk at manscape.com
that's 20 off and free shipping with the
code drunk d-r-u-n-k at man's
escaped.com trim your chesticles with
the bestacles
thank you if you're planning on a summer
trip let me put you on my go-to travel
hack it's called Babel the language
learning app that has sold over 10
million subscriptions in just 10 minutes
a day you can learn a whole new language
and not look like an idiot on that fancy
trip to a foreign country easy fun
babbles extra expertly crafted lessons
are based on real life scenarios so
you'll be learning vocabulary you'll
actually use not that biblioteca [__]
created by over 150 language experts
you're in great hands when you choose to
learn a new language with Babel no
matter what your learning style is Babel
Has something that will work for you in
addition to lessons you can even access
podcast games stories live classes plus
it comes with a 20-day money-back
guarantee right now get up to 55 off
your subscription when you go to
babel.com drunk that's babble.com drunk
for up to 55 off your subscription
Babble language for life well I love All
Quiet on the Western Front but that's a
little I gotta watch that yeah I like
that too you liked it yeah I mean I
thought it was the best movie in 10
years what it's incredible ten years
it's incredible what's what's a good
movie in 10 years well 1918 was a pretty
good or 1907 close that out of the water
blows that out of the water too blows
Dunkirk oh yeah Dunkirk beautiful and
well done and all that but this is a
better story better message ten years in
the last 10 years
parasite was good a parasite was good
all right so I was amazing not as good
as parasite I'll give you that parasite
was [__] awesome yeah yeah I loved
parasite
that was awesome that was good okay but
this might be a better movie that flash
was [__] cool I love Whiplash Damien
gazelle
yeah something like that
um oh I gotta you know what we watch
again I've watched this movie 100 times
I've wrecked in the Pod before but it's
one of the best movies ever in Salamanca
we'll have my back on this one original
Taking of Pelham One Two Three watch it
like a week ago I didn't watch it he's
seen that movie two thousand times
oh what's that you're the one who
originally told me to watch yeah I
[__] love that movie what movie is it
it's it's the Walter Matthau Jerry
Stiller uh Robert Shaw taking a Pelham
one two three every it's a hijacking of
a New York City subway every character
is a piece of [__] in it got it it's why
it's so funny like it's just a hijacking
and they're like people there's a gun to
their head and everyone's like Ugh yeah
like they're not even worried they're
just annoyed that they're they're a
noise it's a classic New Year thing
where they're annoyed the train is
running slow that's great four desperate
heavily it's awesome
oh and that guy Martin Balsam who's in
everything yeah who's in like 12 Angry
Men he's in uh All the President's Men
he's in every movie that guy
going to get shot
laughing at him I do hope I have made
myself it's bad [__] ass it's like
you know what is it's like the Forgotten
one of that era where everyone talks
about like Dog Day Afternoon but this is
on that level dude now what Warriors or
something like that how's the Remake I
heard the Remake sucks
yeah and Denzel I believe Denzel is
awesome but I love it I feel like even
today you can't do that if somebody was
like your attention please nobody would
look up they don't yeah they're airpods
and they just get shot exactly now like
what you said on Rogan about no one
makes a movie with everyone looking at
their phones no it never happened
[Laughter]
oh God now you have a drunk cooking yeah
yeah yeah it's like fake we we wear like
these DUI goggles yeah they simulate
being drunk it's actually worse than
being drunk really yeah we gotta try
that yeah why is it worse than being
drunk because it's not like like drunk I
feel is kind of like a feeling you know
and these goggles it's just it's all
visual yeah it just warps your vision
like crazy yeah that's no fun yeah
your drink of choice usually these days
yeah why is that
um I don't know I just out of everything
I typically just drink gin and tonics
now yeah yeah uh low uh low weight or
whatever low sugar I discovered Thomas
got sugar oh it does yeah yeah I
discovered drinking pretty late though
like the first store me and Tom and I
did I was drinking [__] Long Island
Iced Tea
that's a [__] party Fowler yeah dude
yeah dude how old are you 33.
I remember doing Myrtle Beach and every
table it was trays of Long Island Iced
Teas and would you believe it they
interrupted every [__] joke yeah no
way really all I mean that's like I
remember drinking those as a kid and
that's the one when like your mom your
mom is like what have you done I
remember puking like my guts oh yeah and
my mom would bring me a cup of tea
apparently she didn't really drink I'm
like you know what you know what I'm
craving right now Lipton thanks Mom yeah
yeah more lemon puking my guts out you
ever seen someone make a Long Island
it's like liquor liquor then
it's just a long island with blue
curacao and Sprite instead of shower I
got trash here yeah yeah so anytime you
see that blue drink go across the room
no let's go into a garbage table but you
know that's like but that's like that
makes sense it's a Mormon though because
you're not drinking your whole life and
then you just want to get [__] ripped
that's the bad thing about not drinking
until you're older you don't know how to
drink yeah yep that's why I like them
though because I just get the buzz like
straight away right right I'm just
getting it done I mean that's more than
a buzzer that's five shots yeah I know
yeah it was bad you have two of those
you've had ten shots yeah and everybody
says don't mix alcohol and you're like
that's just like [__] you yeah we're
mixing [__] in one cup yeah dude that
drink is like New York City a lot of
mixing and a lot of insanity and it
doesn't end well yeah and barfing yeah
yeah I we used to drink this might be a
New Orleans only thing it was called
1-800 [__] me UPS
they cut right to the chase did you guys
have those is that like a hurricane
uh I don't know what it was like a pink
lemonade you see him dump on that
country time uh mix in there and the top
of the Igloo cooler and then they would
get a horrible yeah I get like a paddle
yeah those are fun to get ripped my
friend we used to do like Franzia uh
sangria Sangria with Franza it tasted
great but holy [__] you're dead yeah
that's young people [__] you know what
else I used to love doing When We Were
Young is and you can't do this [__] as
an adult
Tabasco and a tequila shot
a little touch it tastes pretty [__]
good but holy [__] never heard of that
oh my God imagine what it would do to
your butthole these days though I mean
that's just like violence I see people
do that with Jack Daniels a lot too
really Tabasco what's the uh what's the
upside the flavor or it goes down easy
huh I do like the burn I've noticed it
who's ordering that it's usually some
guy it's like early in the morning like
a sailor oh wait it's a wake up or yeah
or like like uh when somebody has you
heard of coffee yeah more of a more of
like a [__] you shot when somebody's
like 21 they're like surprise me again
what's called a 252 and that's wild
turkey with 151 so it's just like it'll
just strip the lining off yourself oh I
guess it just burns Andrew I said
surprise me he showed me a naked picture
of my wife I said who said you could
sleep with my wife he said everybody
252. that's what my ex-wade
that will mess you up man I I think all
those shots that like when you're young
you just get away with but uh damn that
would hurt how much I think you put down
now not a lot
oh it's the death of me it's over I also
I like to enjoy the buzz now I don't
want to yeah I don't want to just I got
ripped last night but I didn't I was at
a Knicks game so I didn't I didn't know
until it was too late yeah you don't
really like until it's the fourth
quarter and I'm like am I the only one
yelling in my section
I don't people always bring you shots
like all the time like here's a shot to
a shot with me all the time what do you
do I sometimes I do it sometimes I'm
like I'm not doing it right now yeah all
right go give me the water so it looks
like I'm doing tequila all night but
it's water nice no I I usually if if
it's like celebrate if there's a crazy
vibe in the air I'll do a shot but
I don't I'm more of a sipper than a
shooter I think I think once you hit
your 30s you really are a sipper yeah
yeah I used to be like that when I would
drink I don't drink much but when I
would when I was younger I would just
want to get it done so I'd do like seven
to eight shots wow I don't weigh much so
yeah and then I'm like all right I'm
good yeah but now good for the night
yeah they serve alcohol to the end of
the game
I was in that like a little area so I
kept I would just get a drink like this
big and bring it to my seat so I was
like good I was it's like old gin I was
like where's these River Jazz games they
cut everybody off in the third quarter
they could have went off in the first
quarter they're like it's Utah no one
can drink yeah pretty much yeah I guess
two were out here Jazz game seemed fun I
always wanted to go to a jazz game I'm
I'm going to the Miami Heat Knicks
tomorrow I mean we're taping this in
advance but I'm in Miami I'm kind of
Pumped whoa you're gonna be in Miami
tomorrow I will be and make the game
um we're Landing tomorrow at like two
and the game's at 7 30. and we have a
show the next night we're getting there
a night early I'm friends I'm friends
with one of the Miami Heat players and
he gave me tickets here's the question
am I a Dick if I wear a Knicks jersey I
can't tell us who the player is Duncan
Robinson what's on his podcast
he's a great guy one of the best
Shooters in the world and he's given us
tickets is it a dick move if I roll on
my Julius Randle Jersey that is the
question
probably really is it the owner's box is
it are you I don't know I think it's
fine there'll be other Knicks people in
the room I would go hat no the Jersey
feels like a like a statement I'll
offset it with a Hawaiian shirt over it
so it's open so that way I look at
miami-ish but yeah yeah next well don't
get hammered because then you're the
hammer guy in the Knicks he's got the
Hawaiian shirt like this yeah
so pretty cool to have dunk in your name
I know that's pretty good for a NBA
player Tim Duncan yeah yeah man I like
being called Shooter McGavin yes that
guy [__] ruled oh he was great I'm
just waiting for him to pull like an
Alec Baldwin that'd be the ultimate oh
he's the new shooter
[Laughter]
time
he he I don't think he will and I don't
think he should really yeah I think the
the gun prop person that's their fault
armor armor but he's the producer
if you're the producer you've got to
hire the right people well I don't think
they're bad producers illegal Jeopardy
though I think that's like uh he ethical
no no money thing like you have to owe
the family money but not not you're not
in League you're still making that movie
that movie better be good it's not good
oh my God if you're if you're below 68
on Rotten Tomatoes you [__] up yeah
somebody's fired yeah he fired
sad though it's just his whole life
changed in a blip yeah because some
person some armor yeah [__] up and
screwed the pooch yeah man
yeah although I heard stories like you
hear stories like Jack Nicholson that
departed during the scene just takes a
gun out like of course they actually
didn't know he was doing it but he just
takes a gun out and points it at Leo and
like yeah he looked like nervous and
you're like yeah I'd be [__] nervous
can you imagine actor just takes a gun
out and you're like that wasn't in the
script that was uh did you ever see
sweet sweetbacks badass song the
um Mario Van Peebles no I heard no or
Melvin Van Peebles yeah yeah he's dead
uh there's a movie they made about it
that Mario's son made and there's a
whole part about how they said there was
a real gun in the mix with the prop guns
and they go like he goes that still
gives me nightmares that we never shot
anybody like that was like on the set
they mixed in a real like handgun oh no
what about what's his name Crow oh yeah
uh Jason Lee Jason Lee
I don't know what the hell this is oh
okay
all right we're getting a little little
in the weeds with movies here
all right I'll check that out what else
you got in that brain
useless Film School knowledge and that's
a lot of Simpson stuff and yeah same
it's mostly I don't do nothing yeah
what's the most like Niche movie you
think you know
besides that one
two girls one okay right uh anything by
like Gaspar no way he's a French
director it's like he just makes films
that make you uncomfortable like
irreversible uh which is that Monica
Bellucci one that's got the nine uh nine
minute one frame rape scene it's like
really what yeah it's like you can't you
changed after you see something like
that these comedians are getting trouble
making a rape joke or a gay joke and
this guy's doing a nine minute scene
yeah dude I mean come on what are we
doing here go go yell at this guy or
don't yell at him no way or like anybody
like early Peter Jackson like his stuff
he made in in New Zealand like uh what
is it bad taste his like Alien movies
and okay this is all like you know stuff
you used to have on DVD and now you get
like it's really hard to find streaming
yeah yeah all the banned films what do
you like we got to get it back to you
you're the guest oh man it's all right
porn anal yeah dude all of it man all
right yeah [__] Jewish anal porn yeah
a lot of the a24 stuff oh they're
killing it yeah yeah they're like the
last movie house left they just bought
the Cherry Lane theater what in your
neighborhood ah it's a great room yeah I
don't know if they're gonna do with it
like show movies show plays the
playhouse I don't know it's a playhouse
I hope they don't tour in a movie
theater but they probably do plays I'd
imagine
oh yeah 824 plays yeah they do cool
stuff so I feel like they got a brain in
there that'd be funny Leonardo walked by
he's like hey 24.
so they're right on the edge yeah yeah
so let me ask you you're uh you're on
the internet a lot I am do you because I
I post videos maybe twice a week you do
and it's it's a nightmare I see them
yeah do you have a uh like do you start
to like feel overwhelmed like I have I'm
on this rat race this treadmill and you
can't stop yeah you'll never Escape that
on the Internet it's a bummer yeah it
really sucks do you think it's [__] up
your like sense of Happiness
um no because I think I've been able to
do it long enough that I'm a little bit
desensitized to it yeah so uh yeah I
guess I'm just used to it but I don't
think it ever fully goes away it's like
this weird in-between where I'm okay
with it but I still feel that feeling of
the grind yeah yeah and then it's like
bittersweet because you're like selling
tickets I'm making a couple bucks people
are enjoying it yeah but you know like I
want to just sit down for 10 minutes and
not think about what's my next video
because right when you put one out
you're like okay I'm good and then a day
goes by and you're like what's next yeah
I need another one yeah yeah it's like
the ball up there it's weird that it's
work because it is work it doesn't feel
like work but you're like I need a clip
yeah I know but you're like this is work
yeah but it is yeah it's work run on put
it best he said comedians are never
working and always working at the same
time yeah and it's so true because all
right we need a new bid we got to do a
show we're on a flight so we're like
sitting on a flight not working but
you're still kind of working yeah your
brain's on yeah okay Rosetta but they
said uh they don't pay me to do the
shows they pay me to travel yeah Don
Herrera said that Dom herrero's got some
of the best lines ever you know you know
his joke I love his joke when he says
whenever a comedian will say true story
who cares say something funny as if
anyone's leaving the show man that
Dumber is stunk but boy did he have
integrity
that's such a great comedian's joke
great joke he's a classic man oh yeah
he's so funny do you guys how long does
it take you guys get comfortable filming
for like the internet because I feel
it's different filming yourself to
review but then filming it to like put
it out did you feel like you went
through a period where you like knew you
were recording oh yeah you know what I
mean like I got over that pretty quick
yeah because when you record every show
you get over it yeah yeah I I the thing
is I first started doing it when I
noticed my Comedy Central hour positive
influence when it came out look I was
like I'm getting more people more fans
from the clips than the actual special
yeah so then I and then the big one for
I think people like Mark and myself is
when Comedy Central started shooting
this week at the cellar yeah and we were
forced to write topical yeah and then it
was like they weren't
they were giving us those clips and I
was kind of like well I'm not gonna put
that joke in my ACT yeah so let me get
this up and then those jokes would do
well and when they're doing well it's
the motivation Clips so they let you
yeah once we pushed them but they were
like they were always a step behind yeah
well I was like can I get that clip and
they're like oh we're not doing that and
I was like okay well I got someone to
just cut it for me because I was like
what do you mean we're not doing that
yeah and then a year later they hired
someone to do it I was like do you guys
get that you want this is for your
social media yeah but uh
it I think it made people like Mark and
myself really right current and then
when the jokes do well on social media
you're like well I should write more of
those yeah right that's I mean that's
how I found you was like just Clips
during the time so it works yeah
I I watched some video from like an
internet guy and he said in the future
we'll have uh fatigue content fatigue
yeah because we're all just like
inundated with content we're putting out
content we're watching content
eventually people will be like I can't
keep this up yeah So eventually it'll
just be like back to normal one comedy
special every three years one album
every three years like it'll just go
back to I don't know dude I don't know
praying to God by the way what [__]
this generation is what a bunch of
[__] we've become it used to be
battle fatigue we have content
we're the worst that's a good point but
also comics in the 80s did the same act
for 25 years yeah and we're cutting
Clips twice a week yeah so we are Comics
are doing more we're selling more
tickets than ever like how many
comedians are in arenas right now it
used to be one comic was like Eddie
Murphy then you know Dice Clay and Steve
Martin before that and that was it when
dice did the garden it was like oh that
was a huge and then huge and now look
how many Comics play MSG yeah how many
how many tickets is that was the cap
nineteen thousand eighteen maybe maybe a
little less in that room I think once
they box it off it might be like 15 or
something or 14 but it's still pretty
crazy on the tickets it's still MSG yeah
yeah it's pretty [__] cool yeah
yeah that is the best arena in the world
baby what do you guys like better big
rooms small rooms oh I'm in the middle
yeah I like theaters but I like
um like the 700 1000 yeah yeah
some of the big ones feel that small
like I was at the Wilbur I was like well
that's 1100 but it feels like 300. you
know so I love that yeah one of the
bigger ones Mark and I always talk about
there was one in Seattle called uh the
more and I love it's 1800 I love it it's
like it's [__] perfect it's like
three levels but they're all on top of
each other and you just feel like a wave
yes and it's booming yeah love that I
would I would tape a special there oh
yeah maybe the Wilbur for the next one I
don't know totally those are both
Classics I love
certain cities you just love to you know
like something about San Diego is always
so good San Diego's so good great crowds
they seem happy you know they're fun
it's a fun town yeah how about you what
do you what do you like uh
recently I really like performing in the
midwest I feel oh Midwest is great yeah
you know they're down for whatever yes
yeah love that this this is a bold
statement and feel free to cut the mic
and get a new co-host but I think
there's a lot of steps there this is the
first time in history where
New York doesn't seem like on The
Cutting Edge
I go I feel like I know I know New York
boy Nick's Randall
Westbrook Duncan Robinson but
[Laughter]
all right
I feel like comedically New York used to
be where you got you got good you cut
your teeth you tried new [__] you [__]
around and now I feel like I go to
I go to Philly or Cleveland or Phoenix
and they're they're more open to weirder
material then I come to New York and
they're way more like I don't know about
that I don't want to get involved I
don't wanna I don't wanna laugh at that
and have someone see me laugh at that
and it's the first time where I'm like
come on New York we're artists we're
doing it
does that make sense yeah I know what
you're saying I still all right I still
think though do that it's for your crowd
in New York they're still going to be
great but yeah if you're at a random
crowd right but I think I would say la
is way worse way more
than than New York I still think New
York's great but I I hate question
obviously it's great it's the best thing
in America but I'm still I'm saying it's
shifted comedically where I'm like oh
wow it's weird that the Midwest joke the
Midwest crowd got that joke and you guys
didn't and that's a bummer because I
always think of New York as the Pinnacle
the peak of trend yeah thoughts La you
worked la oh bro I mean I love living in
L.A just because I grew up there but
yeah the Crowds Are everyone's like too
cool to laugh yes they like want to
leave stinks you go to Irvine or Oxnard
or Brea and they're great yeah but you
good in the heart of LA and it's a bunch
of queef Fest
thanks they are Mark's right it is a
queefest yeah really [__] it's not
fun they really get highly and they're
also jaded on top of being sensitive
they're jaded in a way we're like you
see like a famous dude go up in New York
they're like oh my God there's still a
sense of excitement yeah human L.A
they're like yeah whatever yeah right
I'm like that's you're lucky to see this
comic totally I mean Bill Burr said it
first so don't attack me but he was like
I come to New York now I bomb it all day
everybody's like freaked out on my ACT
he's like I got I learned how to be a
comedian in New York and now I come here
and everybody like random Crowds Are
like whoa what's this guy talking about
and he's like what I think covet played
a big role in it I think a lot of people
left and I think it's a new crop so I
think it's just the people that are
coming to the shows now are just much
younger uh so I think they'll get cool
again but I think right now these are
like young people yeah grow up you
twinks come on let's get some life
experience it's just so I think it's
also society and like people are nervous
now you know there's a guy jerking off
on the sidewalk everybody's like no
problem and then I'm like so what's up
with uh Puerto Ricans and I'm like we
gotta get out of here this is dangerous
you know I'm like wait what
we got our priorities are all awack you
know you're half yeah
you have something yeah yeah is it East
L.A what and I try yeah you're trying to
yeah you're trying to get me to where
are you from again I forgot I was born
in Toronto oh right we grew up in L.A
pretty much yeah I grew up in like
actually like a mountain suburb outside
of L.A whoa yeah it was like a weird the
town is like pretty developed now but
when we moved there a lot of the like
the roads were like two lane so whoa
It's when I go to the Midwest I kind of
like go oh man this weirdly reminds me
of like where I grew up on some aspects
of it I remember I was getting picked up
for a gig in Michigan once but the guy
picked me up and uh he had one of those
uh breathalyzers he needed to sell oh
yeah was he like Sam yeah
you won't get up tonight unless you blow
into this but I remember this is like I
can't I don't know why but it's like
this is what the phones have done to us
yeah well he starts breathing into it
and I took my phone at the videotape
he's like please I don't think I'm sorry
it was just Instinct I thought it was
funny that is funny but then it makes
you it does random tests because you
could start it up and then start
drinking so you'll be driving and then
he'll be like I gotta pull over and blow
yeah
I'm gonna I call my dick the
breathalyzer a lot of drunk yeah all
right but uh wow that's crazy yeah
that's really when you gotta get your
life in in shape but it is I'm also like
this is who you sent to pick me up this
isn't exactly the [__] a team you
know hilarious but uh I think it's
working on any bits oh it'll be funny as
if a plane had one of those
[Music]
I can't stand people that don't have
like spatial awareness that drives me
nuts dude people just stopped to look up
at the board like yeah move to the side
you're talking about fat people in seats
tree and I got nothing against the
fatties I was a fat kid my whole
family's fat but
sorry Matt you're a large man but this
is going on second hand fat going around
so we all talk about secondhand smoke
because you're smoking now you breathe
on me why do I have to deal with your
smoke I just think I feel the same with
fat
I feel like I can't comment all right
all right yeah this is not a good look
just three it's like a bunch of skinny
dudes like fat people
it's rude it's inconsiderate
Matt you want to get in on this side I
don't mind you being fat you can be fat
all day you can live your life as much
as you want but when it's encroaching
into my space I know I know but it's
just I totally get what you're saying
but it's just funny to call it rude that
someone's fat like like you just turned
over to them in the seat like do you
mind well like if you have a boner great
you're allowed to have a boner but if
you're a boner you're in a boner to fat
well I'm trying to think of something
gross
the hell I'm just saying if it's coming
into other people's world now it's our
problem too yeah that'd be a problem
from a boner too for sure that's that's
why I used it I hear a lot of skinny
privilege over there all right we folded
away in on it yeah I would say that's
privilege because you're getting my seat
too
um
okay
yeah but the boner will go away at some
point well you could lose weight
but you're like a large human
right yeah even if you were thin you'd
still be a large guy you're six eight or
whatever but yeah how tall are you man
he's four six four yeah he's a Mr Beast
sorry I don't care about the weight but
we're not sitting on a tiny uh single
engine Cessna going to Toledo you know
do you think Airlines should just carve
out like big bone seats
maybe they should charge more but yeah
the hook no just look look the big
people up you know
well somebody's got to pay for those
inches true just saying
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah boners or size
but again people take this as like fat
I'm not I'm not
have nothing I have no hatred towards
the the people of size I'm just saying
if it's uh encroaching on other people's
life
then it's rude
as the same with the bone here's what I
think I think the airlines have made the
seats smaller we've gotten bigger as
people and the airlines have gotten a
smaller so what happens is you should be
mad at the airline for making the seats
also mad at the airline as opposed to
the heavier people I think this is what
the airlines do they get us fighting
with each other like
as opposed to you know actually you're
[__] us it's like politics yeah they
get us fighting with each other we
should be getting along yeah look at the
old seats now that it's funny we were
thinner then and the seats were smaller
smaller yeah I don't know if we were
thinner I think like they were probably
in worse shape but they were they were
smaller people right but you look at a
Woodstock photo they ain't one tubby in
there
and they're all shirtless you know if
they didn't eat they were just on drugs
all day yeah dude whatever works they
also didn't shower they didn't do
anything
[__] hipster burnouts man yeah get a
haircut getting burnt out look at that
what any other airport peeves sorry Oh
no you're fine
[Laughter]
what was it again
spatial awareness oh spatial awareness
yeah yeah
I'm with you yeah you get that a lot
where people just like they'll just
stand in front of the door of a Subway
yeah and I'm like you gotta move or I'm
stuck on the train yeah you're here yeah
people that get up from behind you and
then just they're in front of you yeah
like you know oh that's a problem like
I'm trying I'm on the aisle too and like
the whole family is from four rows back
and all of a sudden they're like lined
up yeah no one stood up yet all right I
hate when they'll do that hole there are
30 people on this flight that have to
make a connection should you let them
stand up first and they just leave it to
us to figure it out right and then you
see the one person cheating it and
they're like well
yeah really life hack you have a
connection get your ass up and run out
of there you're the reason I missed
connections yeah dude yeah whatever
happened to miss connections remember
that that was a big thing
yeah yeah they still have that somewhere
it's got to be there man gotta be pull
it up Tinder took over it's like we can
[__] everybody we want now and so yeah
no I feel like misconnection still has
to be around you know just a little just
a little bit what are the odds that you
both check it in this day and age I know
that's a good point young people even
know what we're talking about right yeah
definitely yeah it was in the paper
originally it wasn't I know but if
you're if you're 19 and you're listening
to this podcast do you know what a
misconnection is not not on Craigslist
not like that Craigslist dude definitely
not all the weirdest [__] you [__]
you need a roommate you find a a [__]
yeah you know it's crazy everything I
did a show a cupboard and uh I mentioned
911 and I said to I said this girl in
the front row I was like how old are you
when I 11 happened she's like I wasn't
born I went what the whole room just
like oh and I'm like I'm like have you
seen it she's like I mean yeah like on
Twitter like that's crazy dude DiCaprio
rolls in yeah
I had a kid drinking at the bar the
other night that said he did his senior
year on Zoom during covid yeah I was
like well you can already I guess you
can drink yeah it's wild yeah dude wow
she was she was 21. and she's legal and
she's never heard of 9 11. well that's
the craziest part like you think oh she
haven't heard a line 11 she's probably
five which is 21. she's 21. yeah yeah it
[__] me up which is so weird because
this is why my beef with the the 21 year
old crop I know all about D-Day I wasn't
there yeah
yeah that is you should probably know
what 911 is yeah well she's from New
Zealand to be fair okay okay that
changes things yeah yeah all right yeah
but you guys ever performed there no no
I'd love to I'm going to Australia in
July oh did you did you like New Zealand
uh I mean it's one of the most beautiful
places oh it's gorgeous
um the crowds are just a little bit
different like so
um they're gnomes no no yeah yeah
they're all small uh yeah they're like
yeah someone was looking for a ring nah
um they're like they're very kind of
like culturally like a little bit to
themselves so they don't they don't seem
like they laugh out loud very often oh I
hate that yeah yeah so after I did the
show uh I got a friend who's from there
his boy was talking to me after and he
could tell I was like a little bit in my
head and he said oh man he said for New
Zealand he's like that's a great set
dude wow yeah he said out here he's like
we're known we like we shake comedians
kind of thing oh we're interested that's
like La yeah I'm not I'm not a big fan
of the uh that's just how we laugh well
[__] learn how to laugh
it's affecting my show totally yes it's
a lot of like you make them laugh and
they're just very kind of like ah yeah
so you're like damn all right yeah we're
gonna maybe I'll just bombing you know
who knows but no but I've definitely
done those there's certain types of
cities sometimes where they're like
that's good for here I mean that's what
Brooklyn shows are like yeah true it's
true I do I feel like they're just like
they're like yeah we nod you're right
yeah parts of Australia were like that
too agreed I've done I did the Melbourne
Fest years ago and it was a lot of like
yeah anyway come on I need it Ireland
had a hint of that too Ireland did have
a hint to that it's very like impressive
yeah I like that so you're like I need
the haha because it's a cut for us it's
the interactive conversation yeah joke
laugh joke laugh it's like a a breathing
thing yeah and this throws off your
Rhythm so you have to like adapt mid-set
yeah it's a different set yeah
definitely where's your favorite place
to perform
this is gonna sound crazy with Cleveland
yeah
hilarities the club is I think one of
the best clubs in the country killer I
love it I love Sam Columbus is great too
I'll be there soon I love Colombia
that's funny bone in the country yeah
that's a good Funny Bone yeah the
flagship yeah
yeah it's uh I remember walking up to
the first time you're crossing the
Legoland and I'm like yes yeah never a
good sign yeah yeah but then you get in
there it's that beautiful tall ceiling
and the Acoustics are amazing yeah yeah
it's like just walking past the lids to
follow our dreams
that's what we went to like Cheesecake
Factory and I'm like man a Cheesecake
Factory on a Saturday morning you just
you're like [__] these kids yeah yeah
that Cheesecake Factory is like a flight
to Orlando it stinks
and all those clubs are always in a mall
and they all have the same it's like
that's a Sephora there's the Apple Store
there's the North Face there's the
Dippin Dots or whatever the [__] and but
then you think Broadway guys must be
like there's the hobo there's the dead
body there's the guy jerking off there's
Elmo with jizz on it and then they go
into the Winter Garden isn't Broadway
weird because it's like literally a dude
with his dick out in Les Mis yeah
just a weird combo
that's true good point New York baby
yeah you said it's lost its Edge dude
did you still see dicks out yeah I saw
one on my way here and I saluted it I
said good for you sir my boner was in
his face
tour is scared yeah the tourists are
back by the way oh yeah they are back
with the Vengeance do you guys feel it
like the difference oh I feel it I live
in the village so it's like all these
people at the park the Washington Square
Park I love walking down McDougall and
Bleaker yeah I'm just glad the homeless
people have like another person to
Target other than me exactly so I'm glad
they're here yeah the decoy yeah
uh do you have any peeves Mark I had
like I got a couple
I had one on the way here how about the
guy with the dog on the Zippy thing with
the he's got the handle and he's got it
can retract and and stretch but he's got
he's on the left side of the sidewalk
the dog's on the right so now there's a
[__] trip wire on the busiest
sidewalk in America oh my God so we're
all doing this [__] and stepping over
and trying to get around it's like reel
it in [__] this goes off a Piva mine
oh the the dog the leash wrapped around
your waist
no no for the dog oh no this is New York
not the Midwest
the leash around your waist connected
the dog you're walking down Broadway and
you're not hiking Everest [__]
yeah
it bugs me you want a dog [__] own it
yeah hold the dog Jerry had that there's
a you know that joke it was the it's
like like he's a Marlin you got him out
on a line that's a great line he goes uh
if you if an alien came down they would
think the dogs ruled us right because
they're pulling us that we pick up their
[__] that we feed them you know true
great big classic either either of you
have dogs no no man do you have a dog
yeah yeah what kind just dude he's a
like a he's a Chihuahua Dachshund mix
he's such a another hint yeah
well they're both mixed it out oh if I
eat it that might give you
I might throw you off too you think that
leans to Mexican now yeah cultural a lot
of white girls have Chihuahuas okay yeah
dude hey dachshund though german yes hmm
dachshunds are cute those little bitty
arms yeah yeah so little yeah yeah the
fat belly and the little arms and legs
you gotta love it the belly's like this
close to the ground yeah it's cute like
my ex
oh yeah I had another peeve oh how about
this guy the guy who keeps harping on
something that he didn't know about you
but it's just continues to hurt your
feelings
I had this guy he's like a a fan he's
like oh good to meet you I did the meet
and greet and he's like man how tall are
you I'm like I don't know 5 10 he's like
wow I thought you'd be taller yeah yeah
what are you gonna do gotta tell you
I really thought you were taller than
that okay yeah yeah I don't know what to
tell you there God you know 510 you come
off as like six six all right
I guess you don't know how tall I am now
you're just bubbing me out yeah so that
guy is annoying yeah I know that one
very well who was that uh comic who came
up with the term comp you so compusel
that's Albert Brooks Albert Brooks yeah
where it's like compliment compliment
insult it's coming and he's like after
the second compliment I get when I'm
doing the meet and greet and just like
stop there get out yeah get out yeah you
know it's like hey I love your show
really funny my wife hates you but I
love you that's a weird one yeah I put I
put your special on for my whole family
they couldn't stand it yeah but I could
be like give them a chance it didn't
connect I don't know why right funny
stuff yeah the ending sucked but good
good jokes brutal yeah dude I get the
height one a lot oh thank you sir I'm
not a yeah the uh paper plane too oh no
I'm chilling man I'm just getting over
something so I might oh yeah everyone's
sick right now yeah everyone I'm talking
to is sick how tall are you Sam I'm six
three but according to complete six
seven though do I um okay yeah uh
Robinson apparent but apparently
according to Wikipedia I'm 510 because I
met a girl and she was and she was like
Oh I thought you'd be shorter is what
she said oh must be nice it was and uh
no but it was but but everyone thinks
I'm and everyone thinks I'm from
Massachusetts because of Wikipedia well
because of Letterman he said that no it
was before that I think he thought I was
from Massachusetts because of that
because because originally Chelsea
Manhattan and someone put Chelsea MA so
they think I'm from Chelsea
Massachusetts so I think that's why
Letterman thinks I'm from Boston
interesting uh what show was he on it
was on Neil's pod and he's like this uh
this young guy Sam from Massachusetts
and it's like no
from Boston
interesting okay yeah I was gonna say
your recent Clips you look [__]
ginormous dude what yeah are you serious
it was just like the whole you're like
the whole real
it's got to be 6 10. I see why he likes
ball must be it sucks to be 610 and not
be good at basketball yeah yeah imagine
being like six are you good at
basketball I played growing up yeah I
could tell six four yeah no but yeah
imagine being six four I'm bad at
basketball and small
are you playing what was your position
man yeah I could see that would you play
any other sports play football too
football really basketball how about
baseball
we're the biggest kid on the court
yeah so were you just putting up double
digits
I hope baseball makes a comeback
baseball's so [__] American by the
way you know what movie watched recently
that is it holds up it's [__]
phenomenal another wreck Bull Durham oh
I love Bull Durham that's a great
[__] movie just rewatched that on a
plane like a month ago that's like kind
of the weirdly like the it's not like
the graduate but it is like the next
cougar yeah yeah Susan Sarandon is so
sexy in it it's a it's a whole [__] fest
movie It's All About banging it's so
good there's so many funny lines I'm
definitely gonna watch it now oh dude
it's fun it's a great script it's funny
as hell yeah Costner's so cool in that
movie he is and uh Tim Robbins he's got
to be six five oh yeah he's a big dude
give it a [__]
yeah she's got a milfy quality for sure
and I love that clavicle it's all
clavicle you suck her neck bone oh yeah
like a rib eye yeah [__] it dude try to
get it out of my teeth put some garlic
on that neck bone
yeah her daughter looks just like her
too pull her up she's on California
she's actually less attractive I think
then did you see the stripper scene with
David accompany him oh oh I take it back
much hotter would you
I'm just a married man Tim Robbins
wow she does look like her yeah how
about that is that is it Tim Robbins or
dad
oh I assume they're still together right
no I don't think they're still together
Jesus Christ dude oh yeah look at the
Hooters big chest yeah look at that Tits
McGee oh my God I'll tell you all right
wow big hooters really seemed
I think that's got to be Tim's daughter
because she's a tall cup of jizz
[Laughter]
Tim Duncan look at that [__]
hachimachi it's kind of weird to be have
a hot daughter because you just know
everybody wants to bang your daughter
that's gotta be a weird feeling it's
weird to have a hot mom too yeah but you
know she made you you came out of there
I think both are weird yeah I guess
you're right but you're probably more
protective but like yeah you knew the
kid growing up with the hot mom and like
that was not good no that's a complex
because you always make jokes about it
like yeah yeah everyone wants to do your
mom yeah okay there you go so glad my
mom looks like uh Paula Deen
hey man that could have been attracted
to somebody I guess you're right black
guys like her they did they did
we [__] that tied turned my friend
a little story behind that oh she said
the n-word oh my mom
Paula Dean do you have gigs you want to
uh plug on this up uh coming tour oh man
no I'm just you could you know go to my
website noelmillerlive.com man I'm I'm
going everywhere dude damn okay Europe
look at that [__] yeah man I'll be busy
yeah dude be all over Midwest Northeast
are you enjoying it yeah dude I am um
stand up was always like my like my
first goal yeah internet stuff kind of
just took over but I managed to like be
on stage while the internet stuff was
growing so I've been getting back to it
for the past like two years I'd say
um nice yeah I think I'm gonna film this
set and then they might just start over
I want to spend like a month out here
after I film it and just grind and hell
yeah yeah dude all right well we'll help
you out spots connections oh dude that'd
be great man I would uh yeah I know this
guy he's brown that's about all I know
yeah we don't know if he's
[Laughter]
yeah dude it's uh it's been great yeah
wow so come see me look at his maid
Dublin Helsinki oslows.com
Birmingham and then London on the 12th
yeah Sheffield on the 17th of May this
is incredible
thank you
what do you got man oh my website's all
backed up I'm all over the road coming
to Oxnard improv that'll be a big one uh
doing Bozeman Montana we just added the
show I went to college there oh yeah
yeah Montana State oh I'm excited I've
never been I said one of the few States
I've never been doing I'm dying to go
yeah I'm all over the place coming to I
got a San Diego all over California La
Sacramento SF then all over your
favorite city Columbus Cincinnati Indy
Kalamazoo [__] Toledo York Bethlehem
Wilmington Delaware Maryland Philly then
I'm doing it's a whole long run it's on
my website samrail.com shows Nashville
well I'm in theater baby Chattanooga
Birmingham Memphis Knoxville Charlotte
Asheville every [__] San Antonio uh
Houston I'm everywhere so I'll see you
on the road Paramount Theater in Denver
is magical oh I'm doing Denver too good
call Santa Fe everywhere samuels.com
shows can't [__] wait drink your
Bodega cat whiskey Bodega cat
whiskey.com Pat come see me at Joey
roses uh Tuesday Thursday Saturday yeah
check it out Salamanca go see Live
Comedy you got that right yeah hell yeah
there you go all right
okay it's all gonna be with Noel Peter
sorry about the uh
yeah yeah yeah
all right heavy set air
all right you guys have been great we
love you keep listening tell your
friends
[Music]
dangerous
woman doesn't look like I remember her
and I get down in the same way
we might
be true
[Music]